Oh what's up you two it's your boy DISA
this is like a green screen to you I'm
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of you oh you
too mr. boy D so I don't say D cell oh
you don't I say what's going on YouTube
and I leave it at that you don't know me
at all
Oh what's going on YouTube that is
something else
LG that's offensive Oh what's going on
YouTube
today we have a little special mission
whipped her hair Emma what are you doing
your hair in my [ __ ] face so today we
have a little special something Dino was
gonna she's gonna sing a song for her
special somebody don't know who you guys
won't know either I don't even know if
she won't even [ __ ] tell me
this is supposed to be a just like a
personal thing and David decided no oh
but that [ __ ] on my YouTube so no I just
thought that it would be kind of fun
because I know a lot of you guys out
there ask you know what what should I
put on my channel you know you you put
on your channel what you like and what's
fun for you a lot of the times you guys
worry about you know what content will
be viral rather than you guys thinking
about what continent you like if you're
not enjoying what you're doing no why do
it at all my friends that's why from now
on I'm gonna be in every single one of
David's videos that's not happening
she's not gonna be in any of my videos
is it David so comedy night David so on
Gina would like to see it what do you
bunch of perverts shine yeah you don't
know yeah but uh I'll be here every day
[Music]
so today it's gonna be a little bit
different I it's not comedy it's not
David it's me singing which I don't do
very well at all so this is gonna be a
little out of my comfort zone and I
asked David to play today
yeah so I mean I think this is a great
example of what you guys can see of kind
of how I thought that YouTube should be
you know what I mean like doing what you
want to do and even stepping out of your
comfort zone you know what I mean so
this is just gonna be Gina doing what
she
wants to do for fun not for a career but
just for fun and putting it on YouTube
and I just want to give you guys that
that encouragement to go ahead and do
that too even though if you're not the
best intergrated if you love doing it
then why not share it with the world and
it doesn't help or it doesn't hurt to
have boobs along with it right yep there
it is
how about you two they're not that great
missus feels like a bag of sand so
hearty so stupid
Deana sounds like Kermit the Frog with
Miss Piggy I love you think something if
I'm why on the moon I'm dead because
there's no oxygen there you have to do a
higher-pitched in LA so here's something
new I'm gonna be singing and I never
seen ever
I don't like singing I was gonna learn
how to play on the guitar but after a
few days my fingers started hurting
really bad and apparently it hurts
really bad to learn you'll play guitar
so I had to enlist the help of this
idiot behind me
David so turdy mm-hmm alright no God
here is nothing
[Music]
why
[Music]
I'll be
[Music]
times worse
[Music]
in space we're here
[Music]
there's
I
[Music]
I keep
it's sometime
anyplace
with you my dear I'm sayin
Oh
[Music]
your shadow fun
all day
Kish
okay
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
anything else you know I'm gonna tell
you right now she's a [ __ ] difficult
last person I'm doing her a favor and
she's open here cursed at me because she
got Flemming her [ __ ] throat three
days I told him to learn this song she
go you sounded like Kermit the Frog when
you first get her eyes aren't even real
the confession nothing on her is real
my love for you is real whatever don't
even know what that means then it takes
pennies Gina's what Vietnamese and a
pincher Van Daan huh what nice how
Michael oh boy so Michael so you guys
don't know I had a huge thing for uh
Vinnie's gross for the longest time and
so the way I try to impress them was
trying to learn Vietnamese but then I
learned all the wrong things I saw
Michael only my uncle ham compared